CONSECUTIVE STARTS FOR SPENCER
KNIGHT, THE 21 YEAR OLE FROM WHT
ROLLS INTO THE MIDDLE OF THE
COMTOIS SENDS IT ACROSS, TERRY
GOT MILANO TRIED TO GET
IT BACK IN
THROUGH THE LOGO.
ABOUT GEREAU, HEY HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE.
BACK COMES ZEGRAS, HIS SHOT IS
HELD BY SPENCER THE
>> JOHN GIBSON GOT SOME HELP
HERE.
AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE.
SCHUSTER.
DUCLAIR AND MAHURA BATTLE FOR IT
IN LITTLE
BIT OF A GRAB, AND THE STICK WAS
AT PARALLEL.
STOP IN BUFFALO FOR BRANDON
MONTOUR BETWEEN ANAHEIM AND
FLORIDA LOW.
ISAAC LUNDESTROM WAS A
>> THIS IS A GOOD LOOK AT
BRANDONEN MONTOUR H WAS BEING
TRAILED ON THE PLAY HIS FIRST G.
THEY WERE TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
CREATE IT INTO THE ANAHEIM
ZONE.
AS CARLSSON WENT DOWNNT, GREAT S
ACROSS TO MAX COMTOIS AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT PRESSURE OF CURG
BACK INTO YOUR TIGHT, BENOIT TEP
AND THAT IS
STRAIGHT UP.
>> NOW THEY'LLNIGHT FINALLY BUNE
DUCKS COULD HAVE HAD THREE NOW E
DUCKS ALMOST
THE OFFENSIVE ZONE. CATS.
LUOSTARINEN FINDSSPECIALLY THISR
WITH ALL THE ISSUES THAT THEY
HAVE HAD THE PRESS BOX.
>> BLOCKER SAVED TO
CURL IT BACK IT TO
THE NET, REDIRECTED OVER TOP OE.
>> YOU SEE ANOTHER
>> TROY TERRY I THINK WAS
THINKINGO GET A SECONDE,.
FOWLER LEADS IT BACK THE OTHER
THAT EVERY PLAYER DEVELOP MILANR
BACK TO
PERIMETER.
DU DUCLAIR PULLS THE TRIGGGG PUG
REACH, NOT